[Musique]
je vais attaquer les commerçants ce
congé flex je dois gras vendu sévère
dessous du cou vigevano inside certains
footballeurs vivent avec seulement 94
mille euros par mois nous ne pouvons
plus accepter une telle précarité en
france
en 2021 pour aider les footballeurs
français et surtout leur campagne avec
laurent ruquier
vincent duluc nous lançons les michto du
coeur de réseau paquet blessés ou
faisais mes chiottes à ben badi ryad des
lycées au caire et secrets protégés de
lamine diack nasser vous avez s'amuse 5
arabe allah les médias accusés d'être en
partie responsables de la situation
pourtant à entendre jaillir bol sonar
haut et avoir aussi ces images des
plages de rio
on peut se dire qu'ils ne sont pas si
responsable que ça images lunaire compte
tenu de la situation à meissen en ex
allemagne de l'est
une des régions les plus durement
touchées par le col vide ce crématorium
est surchargée les chambres froides sont
pleines les cercueils sont entreposés
les uns sur les routes hors france - que
voudrions nous dire à ceux qui ne
croient pas aux convives 19
et bien nous les invitons à venir
travailler avec nous à déplacer un peu
les cercueils
alors envoyez vos dons pour les femmes
des footballeurs à sac chanel des
chaussures louboutin une rolex daytona
en rose d'occasions n'ayez pas honte
même d'envoyer seulement dix mille euros
y a pas de petits dons on compte sur
vous robichaud du coeur
j'en appelle à votre conscience j'en
appelle à vos sentiments à tous quel est
le grand péril de la situation actuelle
l'ignorance l'ignorance plus encore que
la misère l'ignorance qui nous desbordes
qui nous assiège qui nous investit de
toutes parts vous êtes soignant un
moment il faut aussi vous faire face à
vous
responsabilité vous avez une valeur
d'exemple moi je vais vous le dire et je
vais vous le dire de façon encore moins
scientifique
j'en ai plein le cul du virus j'aimerais
qu'on passe à autre chose
on a un vaccin qui a été testé donc je
pense que le rapport bénéfice risque du
vaccin il est favori je sais que votre
ex compagnon s'est fait vacciner
je sais que vous n'êtes pas au courant
il m'a envoyé une petite photo tout va
bien regardez il ya un petit avant après
voilà ça va bien non vraiment il est en
pleine forme
ça fait rire au plus égale à marseille
monique gilardino soixante dix huit ans
est elle aussi candidate au vaccin mais
là encore la tâche se révèle compliqué
depuis que la vaccination elle en a
marseille
didier roules tu est un véritable
phénomène de société
il a un savon à son image et plus
surprenant une collection de bière la
chloroquine dundee que les gens me
demandent quel la chloroquine à
l'intérieur et que si ça va aller
soigner bon
c'est rigolo mais il n'y a pas de plo
rockin effectivement c'est pas là bien
miracle par contre elle est très bonne
au total la sécu a versé en 2010 9 470
milliards d'euros d'allocations
un pactole dont certains tentent de
profiter pour toucher des aides
auxquelles ils n'ont pas droit
toutes les branches de la sécurité
sociale sont concernés la caf qui verse
les allocations familiales la cpam qui
rembourse les frais de santé et y la
branche vieillesse qui alloue des
pensions à nos retraités
les frères sont aux petits soins pour
leurs aînés
tu es rentré à quel âge 21 ans 22 ans il
ya 98 bon bah nous avons mis au jour une
faille dans le nombre de numéros de
sécurité sociale répertoriés il est
supérieur au nombre total de la
population française dans une proportion
que l'administration est bien en peine
de préciser mais qui est sans doute
comprise
entre 2 4 et 6 de plus de 7 millions de
personnes
j'adore ce qui va dégringoler sur la
théière voilà dégringolé sur la théière
noter le à la maison vous préférez avec
du lait le thé ou sucrés je vois très
bien
certaines pensions de retraite seraient
versés indéfiniment une étrange affaire
que les auditions de la commission
denquête ont révélé avec une première
aberration qui a sauté aux yeux des deux
députés
il ya de mémoire 250 assurés sociaux
percevant une retraite qui aurait l'âge
de cent vingt ans de plus de 120 ans
faire
[Musique]
merci j'appelle toute façon bientôt
commis alors applaudissements pour qu'on
vienne peut y arriver cette année
exercice peu commun pour compléter au
théâtre à la télévision sous les spots
au magnifique plan d'eau
qu'est ce qu'il ya et balle dans la
tempe elle vient laquelle tu dis quoi
toi la télé chez moi
moi je suis dans la télé mais ce film
avec wang et regarde quoi par exemple
toi moi c'est déjà pas mal
il s'agit il arrive déjà au pied des
deux murs 2 minutes 10 seulement 2
minutes 10 tu es contrairement à l'année
dernière il choisit le mur classique il
c'est au tour du sol
est-ce que vous avez un piercing téton
tétons gauche absolument pas ce que j'ai
regardé une interview vous avez accordé
à sud radio
d'accord j'ai l'impression là bas c'est
l'anticipation sur scène et sociales et
au pays des ou pas ce que j'aurais fait
là bas ils étaient là dès maintenant
dictionnaire la radio mais ça je suis
bien d'accord c'est le pull oui je ne
puis conclu autrement qu en vous
présentant des voeux qui cette année
auront j'espère que vous leur ai senti
une touche de sensualité que les autres
années elle n'avait peut-être pas de
même qualité
merci un peu comme vlad
on peut pas dire que vous soyez à dire
un habitué de la télévision de nos
avants non vous n'aimez pas ça si
j'adore mes attentes